[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur tv
78 sur radio sensations et sueur marmite
fm également pour ce débat de
l'entre-deux tours aujourd'hui
là ce sont les candidats de trappes qui
vont échanger sur leurs programmes
bonsoir messieurs et merci d'avoir
accepté de participer à cette émission
avec un contexte inhabituel vous n'êtes
pas en plateau pour des raisons
sanitaires aussi bien pour vous que pour
nos équipes nous ne pouvons pas assurer
la distanciation est nécessaire les
règles en revanche ne change pas votre
temps de parole est chronométré premier
tour de table tout comme pour la
conclusion ce sera en fonction de
l'ordre établi en préfecture pour
débuter cette émission rappelle les
résultats du premier tour et
quelques-uns à des enjeux de ce scrutin
et on échange
juste après 15 mars 2020 attrape le
maire sortant apprend qu'il ne se place
qu'en troisième position à l'issue du
premier tour des élections municipales
guy malandain devancé de 18 voix par
othman nasri mais surtout de 446 voix
par son ancien adjoint ali rabais la
gauche se divise un peu plus dans cette
commune sans pour autant profiter à la
liste d'union du principal opposant
trois mois après le scrutin les forces
en présence n'ont pas changé ni leurs
principaux points de programme
chacun espère donc une mobilisation des
électeurs dans cette commune où
l'abstention est souvent élevé au début
de crise sanitaire a amplifié le
phénomène avec seulement 34 % de votants
ce dernier week-end hiver les quelques
trente deux mille trappistes dont le
revenu médian est presque deux fois
moins élevé que les autres habitants du
département et qui attend pourtant des
réponses à de nombreux dossiers à
commencer par celui de l'éducation
retour à la semaine de quatre jours ou
encore accompagnement ps colère on
rappellera que 25 % les habitants au
moins de 15 ans la gestion du logement
cupra également la prochaine équipe
municipale comment protéger les
locataires face aux abus de certains
bailleurs sociaux
comment diversifier l'offre
d'habitations également dans le cadre du
renouvellement urbain sur le plan de la
sécurité il faudra aussi trouver des
solutions afin d'apaiser les relations
entre forces de l'ordre et les habitants
de certains quartiers durant le
confinement la situation restait
difficile avec plusieurs affrontements
et puis symbole du changement du visage
de trappes l'enfouissement de la
nationale 10 afin de recoudre les deux
rives de la commune
l'opportunité de développer des lieux de
vie ou encore des espaces verts toujours
sur tv 78e marmite
fm radio sensations pour ce débat de
l'entre-deux tours avec elle les
candidats têtes de listes qui se
présentent sur trappe othman nasri pour
engagement trappe citoyens liste classé
divers droite par le ministère de
l'intérieur guy malandain pour attrape
la gauche qui agit à liszt classé divers
gauche et ali rabais pour la gauche unie
pour que tu rappes respire liste divers
gauche également un première tout un
premier tour de table pardon rapide je
l'espère pour vous faire réagir sur un
sondage ifop qui a été commandée par
l'un des candidats qui est présent cette
othman nasri ils placent ali rabais en
tête 39 % othman mastrou deuxième 33%
guy malandain troisième 28% sainte et un
sondage qui a été réalisé sur quelques
500 personnes fin mai du 29 au 31 mai
dernier
othman nassr ou une réaction vous avez
souhaité aussi ce sondage quels sont vos
vos constatations ces résultats je crois
qu'aujourd'hui après vingt années de
responsabilité de guy malandain une page
se tourne
je lui ai déjà dit et en ce qui me
concerne j'ai combattu certaines
orientations temps de guy malandain
mais je vais toujours fait dans le
respect et je considère qu'on lui
donnera de la rate et l'essence et de
lessines pour le travail qui a été le
sien et je n'aime par la tournure qu'a
pris cette campagne y compris les
attaques dont il fait l'objet dès que je
fasse mois l'objet d' attaque c'est
naturel j'ai dirigé l'opposition
municipale pendant six ans suis le seul
ici à défendre exactement les mêmes
idées dans le projet que celle que j'ai
défendu pendant les six années de mandat
mais je n'aime pas effectivement on
donne le sentiment que on prend les
trafics pour des idiots et qu'on leur
premier mon énergie est donc ce sondage
évidemment il montre simplement que
aujourd'hui il ya un duel qui se joue
dans cette élection et ralliera b une
part adjoint monsieur malanda dissidents
aujourd'hui et la candidature d'une
heure locale que je porte avec mustapha
larfaoui et je crois que ce sont deux
visions totalement différente pour la
rue et en ce qui me concerne je défends
les mêmes idées je les ai déjà dit et
surtout je ne veux pas de retour en
arrière que serait l'élection de
monsieur rabais à la tête de notre ville
et donc je continuerai à défendre
jusqu'à la dernière minute est bien le
seul choix qui est possible seul
véritable changement la seule véritable
alternance puisque je suis le seul à ne
pas avoir été aux responsabilités
c'est-à-dire cette candidature d'union
locales qui ne se soucient que de
l'intérêt de la vie que nous portons
avec mustapha larbins guy malandain
réagit on entendu ma nation parler d'un
duel pour l'instant c'est un duel à
trois ça t'apprend s'appeler un tel
montage
j'en ai tellement entendu de sondages en
tous genres et toutes choses elles sont
des pas la réalité la réalité c'est ce
que feront les électeurs dimanche
prochain et et on verra alors ont
encensé par un duel c'est comment dire
un combat politique sociale l'humain
pour des choix politiques différents
elle ce qui empêchera de la chose que
j'ai partagée avec monsieur la trousse
et le respect de ce qu'on a fait ce
qu'il a été et est de l'engagement qu'on
on appris voilà en tout cas moi je reste
avec mes amis entièrement disponible
pour continuer à faire le travail qu'on
a fait depuis 20 ans sur la ville qui me
permet de rappeler pour ceux qui étaient
là il ya vingt ans et ceux qui sont là
aujourd'hui quand il regarde la ville de
trappes
au niveau de l'éducation au niveau
social au niveau urbain au niveau
culturel que donne un exemple en passant
d'être commencée mais on va aborder les
thématiques emmené thématique du site
mais ne donne un exemple constat les
électeurs choisir de leur choix mais
c'est pas des phoques qui fait kiffer la
dune élection déjà vu un tel match où
est votre réaction
guy malandain à l'irs avait également
c'est un sondage qui vous donnent
gagnant en tout cas bon appétit mans
rapide pour dire que bell remercie
othman d'avoir commandé aux frais du
contribuable un sondage qui confirme le
monde avance la perspective de ma
victoire mais je veux dire un bourg
trappistes cette victoire potentielle
elle vous appartient c'est à vous de
vous mobiliser pour aller voter parce
que les sondages n'ont jamais prédit le
résultat d'une élection bien au
contraire
qui aurait imaginé que je sois candidat
qui aurait imaginé doucement en tête de
l'élection municipale très nettement en
tête de 10 points devant et de conduire
d'ailleurs votre future mère des jeunes
et calmes et fera voler dès lundi soir
il tenait pas interrompu monsieur
malandain soyez capable d'écouter
allez-y à lire mais bon pas empiéter sur
même temps de parole allez je vous
laisse répondre à ça je vous passerai la
parole pour que je ne réponde parole
parce qu'on m'interroge systématiquement
ça c'est pénible respecte ainsi la mort
n'étant qu'à écouter l'autre je vous
disais ce n'est pas un duel il m'en a
raison il a trois candidats les trois
sont respectables
seul donc pouvoir donner je vous
rappelle monsieur n'à seront plus vous
êtes effectivement dans la critique
permanente du travail de dimaga et son
équipe depuis six ans vous avez sans
cesse de guy malandain permanent avec
des propos injurieux
j'ai là intacte de 2014 entre deux eaux
je peux le présenter à la caméra trapu
aux moments avec des actes violents du
malandain qui pour vous et quelqu'un qui
à l'époque à saint géry inconnu dans
votre peau tu peux continuer à citer les
propos que vous lui vous l'avez asséné
avec les violence inouïe les murs mais
rien qu'à les immondes et s'échanger sur
les thématiques non chers wilfried que
ces critiques permanentes que vous
portez depuis six ans dans une forme
d'agressivité qui vous caractérisent ne
vous en même pas permis de dépasser qui
malandra dit quand on est à 18 mois la
ville ont le regard très clairement ce
sera une audible si vous parlez plus
nous en même temps c'est juste inaudible
pour les téléspectateurs et les
auditeurs des différentes radios qui me
suivent donc à alésia les rabais en deux
mots pour conclure et autres menaces que
je vous passe la parole pour conclure
tout simplement six ans de critiques
permanentes ne nous ont même pas permis
de dépasser le score de guy malandain 18
voix vous séparent seulement en grèce et
chacun des concurrents
il est votre égal aujourd'hui c'est les
trappistes qui nous débarrasserons et
soyez capable de ne pas considérer qu'il
est déjà éliminé de la compétition
vous avez réagi les uns les autres je
voudrais un mode othman nastro
puisqu'ali rebelles vous avez évoqué un
sondage finances et de quelle manière
sur le frais des contribuables peut-être
je voudrais juste la réponse d'autres
magnats sco sur ce sujet c'est
évidemment sur les comptes de campagne
qui est parfaitement légal mais
simplement
pardon monsieur rabais dont méthodes de
campagne sont détestables
collé des affichettes sur les affiches
les uns des autres quand vous les
arracher pas dans leurs mythes le
contraire de se poser par les bons amis
la nationale les pratiques de vos amis
et elle d'être gay se demander ce
respect que nous donnait pas à vos
interlocuteurs et surtout aller aux
élections
[Musique]
bon programme j'avais planté chat
pendant les lumières pendant des années
vous le redis je vous le confirme c'est
inaudible pour l'hôtel et les attaques
dont j'ai fait l'objet laisser finir
votre mana ce groupe à mirabel et c'est
fini rotman d'assaut et nous passons aux
thématiques votre mandat seront belles
choses en quelques mots rapidement qu'on
passe aux thématiques une fin de
campagne
il y à un durcissement simplement on
n'avait qu'une campagne et on doit
parler d'eux sur avait depuis le début
avec des miracles idées ou les montages
vidéo anonyme les affiches arrachées
dans leur même là mais je ne peux pas
supporter ça vous les débats monsieur
richie c'est vous que j'interpelle soit
entre auprès des populations monsieur
rabaisse je vous entends autres menaces
je vous laisse juste terminer en deux
mots on a compris que vous ne mettrez
pas d'accord de toute façon qu'on
termine sur des polémiques avec derek
taylor mais vous le problème le problème
c'est qu'elle allait y avait un monsieur
rappel s'il vous plaît elles n'ont parlé
parlons sécurité genre pour ça que ça
devrait pouvoir être le cas si vous me
laissez juste terminer monsieur rabais
s'il vous plaît voilà laissez moi juste
terminée donc monsieur nation en demies
votre conclusion sur ce sujet là si vous
avez un mot à répondre à les rabais et
nous passons aux thématiques cinq
secondes 6 mai sur un an est élu à la
tête de la ville je suis inquiet pour
son avenir
merci à vous trois pensées première
réaction on va parler du fond va parler
des projets maintenant à la question de
la santé de la solidarité on va en
parler forcément c'est une thématique
d'actualité avec la crise sanitaire
mondiale
justement othman nassr où l'épidémie de
kobe de 19 est ce que ça a changé aussi
vos priorités est ce que votre programme
s'est adapté
[Musique]
évidemment traiter une crise d'une
violence sans précédent et chacun dans
cette crise était censé jouer son rôle
en ce qui me concerne en tant qu élue
régionale avec le maire guy malandain
parce qu'il aimait et c'est comme ça et
il le sera jusqu'à la dernière minute et
c'est bien normal
mon rôle était surtout de m'assurer que
la ville était bien l'approvisionner en
masquant matériel sanitaire est ce que
nous avons fait dans le cadre
républicain le plus total et sur ces
sujets là il ne faut pas évidemment
mélanger les genres ou jouer il faut
aussi que chacun respecte les règles de
confinement et la campagne était
suspendue durant ce temps là je vous dis
à toutes fins utiles
maintenant la réalité c'est que nous
savons que les besoins étaient déjà
criant avant cette crise et non le
projet il n'a pas changé avec cette
crise
ça nous a confirmé un certain nombre de
sujets et le décrochage scolaire que
nous avions déjà c'est pour ça que cette
question du numérique à l'école et on va
y revenir était absolument majeur parce
que tout simplement à l'occasion d'une
crise comme celle là ce sont des outils
numériques qui ont permis dans les
villes les mieux équipées et ce n'était
pas le cas de trappes de permettre et la
continuité pédagogique c'est pour ça
qu'il faut qu'on accélère comme d'autres
villes l'ont fait le sujet du numérique
à l'école c'est aujourd'hui le
département et l'agglomération qui
financent 70%
le coût de son déploiement mais
naturellement il va falloir qu'on
réinvente mot solidarité qu'on cherche
beaucoup plus d'efficacité dans l'action
sociale de la ville il ya des choses
utiles qui sont faites aujourd'hui par
les services municipaux je ne le
conteste pas voyez je ne suis pas dans
la critique systématique contrairement à
ce qu'on dit je vois tes trois quarts
des délibérations quand elles vont dans
le bon sens mais je ne dis pas
aujourd'hui le contraire de ce que j'ai
répété pendant six ans je crois que nous
pouvons gagner plus d'efficacité au
service des habitants et leur donner un
meilleur service public
ça a été notre projet depuis 2014 ça
sera notre projet demain dès le
lendemain de l'élection et di malanda
vous avez forcément peu plus de retard
sur le temps de parole je vais vous les
avez redonné même si tout le monde n'a
pas encore répondu sur cette question la
solidarité santé et puis l'adaptation
votre programme aussi à lire à des deux
minutes quarante othman nasri 3 minutes
47 et 10 malandain une minute 37 10
ballons dans est ce que cette situation
cette crise inédite à a fait évoluer
votre programme et puis si on élargit un
petit peu aussi est ce que on peut
revoir d'entre dans votre programme les
propositions concernant la santé la
solidarité
cet événement dramatique au niveau de la
france et au niveau international et que
ça recommence en allemand et donc il
faut être extrêmement prudent
le souci que nous avons porté dans
l'équipe qui restaient en responsabilité
avec les services avec des partenaires
est vraiment de soutenir
je sais pas si le mot combien on
admettra le sens que je lui donne d'aidé
d'être solidaire avec toutes celles qui
en a des besoins sabah de l'enlèvement
six qu'il y ait un sens du retrait du
montant des loyers pour les entreprises
de la pépinière je donne un exemple
jusqu'à la mise en place des aides
financières des d'alimentaire
distribution de que le soutien et
l'organisation de la scolarisation pour
les enfants qui étend des parents
souhaité qu'ils soient scolarisés et
avec un travail absolument
extraordinaire de la part des
enseignants qui étaient là les excuses
de la part des services municipaux qui
sont allés porter des masques aux
personnes qui voulaient pas se déplacer
bref un vrai travail normal enfin voilà
et solidaire quand on a le jeu veut dire
le chemin artistique et et philosophique
qui est le mien ça paraît tout à fait
naturel et tout le monde tout le monde
s'y est mis je voudrais au passage parce
que le ramenait tout à soi même sur un
sujet comme ça dans une faillite rallye
pour moi un petit peu délicat de gens
d'affaires pour core i3 je voulais
saluer aussi le travail de l'ensemble
des agents de l'hôpital de l'ouest
parisien qui avec lesquels on a
travaillé en coordination permanente
pour faire l'autre faire mon mieux dans
la situation où nous c'était et donc je
les salue au passage on emprunte pour
applaudir tous les soirs quand tu te
montrer qu'il était sympathique mais
aussi pour dire que
il faut il faut les remercier je parle
des personnels de santé et il faut les
remercier pour toujours pas seulement un
château mais simplement une
revalorisation de leur métier parce que
maurice eu raison que je ne pense pas je
ne compte pas en politique parce que
c'est l'été président j'en ai vu une
telle série des gouvernements ont des
vues une série que tous ont un cahier
durant leur sac à dos parce que la vie
pas si facile et que sam et en os il
fasse il est critiqué mais c'est pas
facile à faire je dis simplement qu'il
faut éveiller deux éléments dans notre
pays et et la collaboration d'un sauna
tiguan mulâtre à et participe d'une
petite mesure c'est la santé et
l'éducation
il digère national à l'éducation ça sera
le thème juste après guy malandain vous
avez pris un petit peu plus d'avancé
minutes de plus quand madonna souhali
rabais on ne vous a pas encore entendu
sur ce sujet de la santé de la
solidarité et puis peut-être deux points
nouveaux qui sont apparus dans votre
programme avec cette crise sanitaire
inédite
on est tout à fait apte à prendre la
parole
excusez secondes gilles je parle de la
vie je parle pas malade
la ville se créer un million d'euros
excuse-moi ali rabais donc je voulais
effectivement assisté à la suite de guy
malandain sur le travail des
fonctionnaires de l'état
le centre communal d'action sociale a
déployé une action considérable pour
venir en aide aux personnes notamment
âgées qui n'était pas en mesure de se
fournir en repas en colis alimentaires à
guy malandain lui-même d'ailleurs avec
son équipe a mobilisé les moyens ici
paris et utilement pour aider ce qui est
des plus fragiles d'entre nous sur la
table confinement je les lis tu attrapes
comme trappistes cette période de
confinement et j'ai touché du doigt la
grande vulnérabilité dans 52 familles
qui ont besoin dans ces moments-là des
services publics et c'est là que le
service public local communal prend tout
son sens je veux également profité pour
saluer j'espère que vous partagerez avec
moi ce salut amical aux bénévoles des
associations de la ville de trappes qui
se sont considérablement déployés qui
parfois d'ailleurs viennent combler les
lacunes des pouvoirs publics compris de
l'état on est remplaçable de créer des
chaînes de solidarité locale
ils permettent en proximité d'aller
des personnes qui en ont le plus besoin
notamment art du bénévolat pour aider
les enfants à ne pas décrocher de
l'école et ça me permet également de
d'évoquer ce troisième catégorie de la
population de personnel soignant
évidemment nous avons applaudi à 20
heures tous les soirs les enseignants
qui ont déployé toute leur énergie leur
créativité et leur disponibilité pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que les enfants
ne décroche pas trop de l'école même si
nous considérons avec l'équipe la gauche
ni pour que tu rappes respire que ce
trimestre décollement caen aura des
conséquences considérables pour les
familles pour les enfants qui aborderont
la prochaine rentrée avec un retard avec
un handicap et donc nous avons
totalement revu nos priorités notamment
pour cet été et nous avons élaboré un
plan d'eau municipal de crise que nous
avons soumis ou trappistes qui nous ont
d'ailleurs apporté des contributions à
terme l'idée et nous avons décidé de
porter des actions nouvelles ou les
rendre prioritaire
cet été nous ferons pas 500 enfants en
colonie de vacances et nous profiterons
positif pour permettre à ces enfants de
réviser de travail et de rattraper une
partie du retard pour aborder la rentrée
dans les meilleures conditions
nous allons également travailler sur la
question des seniors
il faudra cette épée être plus que
jamais vous voyez la qualité déjà que
nous frappe en proximité de nos seniors
pour aller à domicile s'assurer qu'il ne
manque de rien ils ont de la compagnie
et que cette période difficile de l'été
à passer à la trappe ou sans semble
puisque vous le savez que les voyages
sont considérablement réduits ne soient
pas trop difficile à traverser pour
cette catégorie de la population
un troisième élément auquel beaucoup de
paroles de le paquet vous le savez
habituellement les familles à piste parc
en vacances pour certaines retourne au
pays pour d'autres vont vie et nos
belles régions françaises
cette année nous serons en quelque sorte
un peu confiné à tra il faudra y voyez
vraiment en 10 secondes sinon vous aurez
trop d'amour secondes vous exprimer un
climat qui permette de vivre dans
l'apaisement les uns avec les autres et
donc une équipe de médiateurs renforcer
ira dès les prochains jours à l'élection
lutter contre les nuisances notamment
les rodéos moto escouade de pied
d'immeuble qui pourrissent la vie du
quotidien de notre api et nous nous
mobiliserons fortement sur ce semestre
ou si vous souhaitez réagir vous avez
plus de retard près de deux minutes de
retard sur ali rabais notamment guy
malandain quatre minutes 34 vous avez
vous une minute de retard mais on a
d'autres sujets aussi abordé autre
manoeuvre aussi vous souhaitez réagir ou
si on peut déjà abordé aussi la question
de l'éducation qui a été abordé un petit
peu là à travers les discussions
peut-être comment aussi la municipalité
si vous êtes élu pourrait se positionner
en termes d'éducation pour aider ces
élèves ces étudiants qui n'ont pas pu
aller travailler pendant cette période
de confinement d'un mot je parle juste
pour éviter les confusions du jeu forêts
etc je voudrais simplement signaler tout
le monde le sait que le temps le temps
des vacances dans les conditions
actuelles était prête travailler et
chacun a reçu les documents de ce qu'ils
veulent c'est pendant ce temps là ne
vous inquiétez pas oui effectivement je
ne veux pas à m'approprier initiatives
qui sont déjà prévues par les services
municipaux et quand j'entends parler de
500 places des colonies je me demande
toujours aux sans les financements et
qui sont des partenaires et comment est
ce qu'on y travaille pour vous s'il vous
plaît vous avez demandé chacun puisse
s'écouter vous entendu je vous demande
juste un bac je vous laisserai réagir
ensuite en fonction de l'égalité du
temps de parole antoine lascault le vrai
sujet que nous avons c'est effectivement
les stages de remise à niveau parce que
là il faudra faire un effort
supplémentaire et sur la question des
loisirs vous savez moi j'ai demandé la
gratuité de l'île des loisirs cet été
parce que c'est bien la moindre des
choses d'ailleurs la question de sa
tarification est un vrai sujet à part
entière simplement je me battrai
l'attention sur le sujet sanitaire
puisque la question de la santé est un
vrai sujet à trappes et moi je considère
désolé de dire que c'est un les échecs
de la municipalité actuelle équipe en
place contre il me suis rappelé qui a
été adjoint pendant six ans parce que
attention ça les fascine nulle part
et quand je dis ça je ne blâme personne
néanmoins néanmoins nous avons une
obligation de moyens et quand on n'a
plus aucun médecin généraliste dans tout
le quartier je reste je crois que c'est
un vrai sujet j'ai obtenu financement
d'une maison de santé
cette ville théâtre merisier de la
région de 250 millions en 2018 et hydro
l'engagement pour faire la même chose en
quartier jaurès
je crois que cette crise nous a aussi
appris l'importance vitale que nous
avons pour avoir continué à avoir des
services de proximité y compris sur le
sujet sanitaires y compris quand ce
n'est pas facile mais nous le devons aux
trappe et en particulier aux personnes
âgées quand de plus en plus de
difficulté évidemment à se déplacer
c'est travail de proximité qui fait part
agents de la ville je le conteste pas il
fera l'amplifier parce qu'il y en a
aussi beaucoup encore aujourd'hui qu'ils
se sentent un bandeau ali rabais en deux
mots vous avez encore de l'avant ce donc
du coup ce sera très rapide si vous
souhaitez répondre une réponse factuel
nationa seront l'une des priorités du
futur maire doit être d'aller chercher
des financements là où ils sont à
l'extérieur d'autres notamment pour ne
pas avoir à augmenter les impôts
puisque vous passez votre temps à
promettre d'augmenter les services tout
en réduisant les grains où il ya une
incohérence que je dénonce et moi je
vais vous dire en vous répondant
factuellement où je vais aller chercher
l'argent pour financer les 500 colonie
de vacances parce que vous n'avez
peut-être pas encore réussi à perdre est
factuellement alliera mais justement dit
c'est ce que j'en ai dit tu fais une
ridicule a dit allez-y vous êtes
pédagogue vous le savez vous connaissez
les règles c'est bon vous ne le savez
peut-être pas mais l'état finance cet
été à hauteur de 400 euros par enfant
par semaine des colonies de vacances
combattez rentrer nationale m'a dit moi
mais il faut pas de réduire de mon temps
de parole s'il vous plaît autrement dit
malandain vinifera diariste après
alliera belge
excusez moi tous les trois si le mans
s'il vous plaît tous les trois ça ne
sert à rien de parler en même temps que
moi en fait ça va juste que réduire la
durée de l'émission à la question à lire
mais les rabais je pense que vous
m'entendez voilà même si vous continuez
à parler je vous demande juste à tous
les trois d'arrêter de parler en même
temps les uns sur les autres c'est juste
inaudible ça ne sert à rien pour les
électeurs et les électrices qui nous
suivent sur les antennes de radio
sensations de marmites fm je le rappelle
est de tv 78 voilà pour la petite mise
au point
à lire ab allez-y vous avez 10 secondes
que les autres puissent s'exprimer et
que l'égalité du temps de parole soit
respectée merci donc l'état finance à
hauteur de 400 euros par semaine par
enfant des séjours dans le cadre des
colonies vacances apprenantes loisirs et
révision pour tous les enfants
voilà ce que nous chercherons comme
financements pour pouvoir faire partir
nos enfants en vacances
magna ce coup je vous fait réagir aussi
et du coup par rapport aux différentes
thématiques et nous avons abordé j'ai
peut-être élargir aussi parce que vous
parler les uns les autres d'aller le
chercher des financements ailleurs
l'élection se passe à trappes il ya
aussi une intercommunalité il ya aussi
un département il ya aussi une région
comment vous allez travailler les uns et
les autres avec ses différentes
structures qui sont en fonction des
résultats et de la victoire de l'un ou
l'autre des deux pas de la même couleur
politique
othman lascaux c'était évidemment un
sujet puisque les principaux partenaires
et films en cours de la ville c'est
l'agglomération département et la région
j'entends parler maintenant de l'état
mais la réalité c'est que monsieur
rabais ce couple de toutes ses
partenaires parce qu'il a une attitude
qui est cliente qui agressif qu'il passe
son temps malheureusement à les insulter
et donc c'est compliqué de venir
expliquer que demain on va faire tes
tatchou des tas de choses quand en
réalité les partenaires ne suivent pas
et c'est pour cela que il faut premier a
travaillé sérieux là dessus il ne pas
décevoir au lendemain d'une élection
quand je vois que monsieur ravi de son
projet coûte 2 millions d'euros on voit
bien que je ne serais ce que c'est les
propositions qui sont faites aujourd'hui
nous mettent parfois bien au-delà de ces
deux ce chiffrage
toutefois la réalité encore une fois
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faut être très
pragmatique et or mater de cette crise
il ya un sujet qui sera abordé donc j'en
profite pour le faire maintenant ces
sujets économiques
parce que nous allons aussi avoir une
économie j'entends le sujet scolaire
j'entends le sujet évidemment sanitaires
et sociales mais il ya le sujet de
l'emploi et sur ce sujet là nous avons
fait beaucoup avec l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines en créer des
places de formation 320 limitée du
numérique gratuite j'aimerais que les
trappistes et accès plus facilement à
cette dynamique économique de 50 ans une
vie où j'ai redressé la pépinière
entreprises proto lille et des outils
qui existent et la vie doit travailler
davantage contraire avec ses partenaires
agglomération département région que je
connais bien et qui aujourd'hui sont
indispensables pour relever tous ces
défis et en particulier des finances
vous êtes à 5 minutes 08 de temps de
parole othman d'assaut 6,32 à l'irad à
6,47 guy malandain et si vous souhaitez
réagir à tout ce qui a été dit sinon je
propose d'avancer aussi après dans le
débat ve vous écoute je répondre à la
première question le partenariat
bien entendu il a un nombre important de
partenariats dès que le département la
région l'état avec ses caractères h
l agence de renouvellement de
renouvellement urbain et ces éléments là
sont fondés sur un travail important qui
qu'il est né sait comment guide domine
l'avenir l'avenir de la ville de trappes
à la fois sur les plans éducatif et
l'équipement des écoles duty
informatique je vais pas refaire le tour
le développement du commerce et reste un
problème que monsieur
à aborder c'est normal monsieur c'est ça
une part de sa responsabilité à la
communauté partage c'est bien travaillé
ensemble ces îles si l'emploi l'emploi
est un autre un problème partout et je
le disais hier en d'autres circonstances
y en d'autres lieux
c'est un problème qui va s'amplifier
dans les mois à voir dans l'année qui
vient
en conséquence de la période que nous
avons passé et qui n'est pas terminée
contrairement à ce que beaucoup de gens
croient et donc le travail coopératif si
j'allais dire de jean poids souvent le
no partenariat entre les collectivités
territoriales je parle bien de toutes
les collectivités territoriales dont
l'adjoint de trappes parce qu'il y a on
a quand même cinq 5 zones d'activités et
d'emplois ils ont des technologiques en
cours de préparation avec plaisir et ils
encourent et faire un travail où chacun
aura sa place et qui s'ajoutera à ce que
font déjà les vies en tout cas c'est que
tu es la ville de trappes et sur le cac
le cap emploi alliance territoriale et
serge n'est pas rentrer dans les détails
mais la solidarité passera aussi par de
nouvelles méthodes de nouveaux
partenariats de nouveaux systèmes
financiers pour sauver et et dynamiser
l'emploi ce qui va nous demander des
choix d'aisé des efforts et qui va
demander du temps on sera peut-être que
nos concitoyens sachent ça on sera
peut-être obligé de faire des choix qui
enlèveront des services des prestations
qu'on fait aujourd'hui c'était tout à
fait naturel qu'on serait amené à
diminuer parce que il faut pas diminuer
le chômage et les difficultés que ça
crée dans des familles avait quand même
une situation particulière et ce n'est
pas de dire ça à trappes et depuis 25
ans je connais cette ville on a vraiment
un nombre de familles assez important de
la vie quotidienne
et très difficile sur le camping de plus
en plus d'une minute 30 par rapport aux
autres candidats à lire à b vous
souhaitez réagir
ouï dire à moore nationale ce coup mais
connaît le fonctionnement des
collectivités locales et notamment les
coopérations sont nécessaires et qui
sont permanentes
vous savez j'étais maire adjoint aux
sports il lui l'un de mes premiers actes
a été avec le soutien de guy malandain
d'investir ou transformer un terrain de
foot de la ville de trappes en terre
sainte et c'est un investissement de
près d'un million d'euros
on a pu le financer par ce conte moi
comme adjoint aux sports j'ai pu
solliciter du département une subvention
relativement modeste 150000 euros sur un
million d'euros et qui a permis de
financer une partie de l'investissement
sur une autre partie était financée par
la casse pipe la communauté
d'agglomération sur les fameux son
concours et c'est important que les
trappes hissage comment tout cela
fonctionne sinon que leur racontais des
histoires en leur indiquant si demain un
autre candidat est élu qui n'est pas du
même bord politique que la droite qui
gouverne le département ou la casse ou
la région alors vous près les robinets
non seulement c'est un chantage
politique mais il faut je suis adjoint
j'ai été adjoint aux sports et j'ai
obtenu de saint quentin en yvelines
les familles seront de concours que guy
malandain connais très bien qui
permettent de sécuriser une enveloppe
budgétaire pour la vie de trades ces 8
millions d'euros qui sont fléchés vers
cra et ses trappes qui dispose d'un
droit tirage lui permet de financer ses
projets sur les fameux fonds de concours
qui relève du pacte financier que si la
ville de trappes l'ensemble des douze
communes dans le cas d'un contrat de
partenariat
l'agglomération de saint quentin c'est
une coopérative de communes ce sont
douze maires qui travaillent ensemble
quel que soit leur bord politique
il ya des maires de gauche il a des
merdes centriste il a des nerfs de
droite est alors le discours qui
consiste à dire je suis le seul à
pouvoir aller chercher les financements
des partenaires est contredit par les
faits depuis des décennies maintenant
donc s'il vous plaît respectez
l'intelligence des trappistes ne les
prenez pas pour des idiots guy malandain
maire socialiste a été financé par tous
les partenaires
quelle que soit la couleur politique ali
rabais mer demain de la ville de trappes
aura le même soutien
je pourrais vous dire est ce serait
grotesque chez pierre bédier le
président du département
si vous étiez une pierre bédier dont
vous avez été l'adversaire dans les
scrutins internes à l'ump au public 1
pourrait décider de ne plus financer ici
je disais ça je saurai grotesque parce
qu'évidemment pierre bernier n'est pas
seulement votre animosité personnelle
vis-à-vis de lui alors je vous ai
entendu vous êtes préfet vous êtes à 9
minutes de temps de parole guy malandain
huit minutes othman associe minutes 30
nous avions plusieurs thèmes que nous
avions prévu d'aborder bien évidemment
nous n'aurons pas le temps il reste une
dizaine de minutes d'émission
je renvoie tout de même les électeurs
les électrices aux débats du premier
tour qui peuvent retrouver sur notre
site internet où nous avions abordé à
bon nombre de ces différentes
thématiques
mais pour poursuivre les échanges
ottomane mas rouge vous laisse répondre
et ensuite guy malandain aussi voulait
intervenir et j'aimerais qu'on garde un
temps rapide aussi pour parler du
logement vous parliez guy malandain tout
à l'heure de ces familles en difficulté
aussi il ya des problèmes d'insalubrité
dans certains quartiers voir comment la
mairie peut aussi agir sur ça j'aimerais
qu'on ait en temps pour échanger sur sa
avant vos conclusions wattman moscou oui
simplement pour revenir se tendre n'ai
jamais dit que c'est une question de
couleur politique et surtout après avoir
construit l'iss d'unions locales qui est
un vrai dépassement des clivages
politiques avec moussa fall harbaoui qui
a géré sensibilités politiques de gauche
qui n'est pas la mienne donc c'est pas
moi qui les boudent est une question de
couleur politique c'est une question de
fonctionnement de méthode et de
personnes et bien sûr que monsieur
malanda était légitime à demander des
financements des partenaires je crains
que de mac monsieur rabais ce ne soit
pas le cas parce que il a un
fonctionnement clivant diviseur qui
s'est vérifié tout au long de son
parcours politique et donc je crains que
malheureusement l'agglomération
département large on a envie de
travailler avec quelqu'un avec lequel il
n'y a pas de relation de confiance
j'en prends pour preuve que l'exemple
qui est donnée ici sur le terrain
synthétique la décision avait été prise
avant même l'élection de monsieur rabais
et je crois que monsieur malandain
pourra le confirmer puisque à l'époque
j'étais déjà surtout j'étais candidat à
l'élection ce sujet tout mais qui que
encore une fois il ne faut pas dire l'un
vertes ce qu'on a fait pendant six
années et moi on peut me reprocher
beaucoup de choses et certainement pas
de tenir un discours de vérité au
tracklist est d'avoir les moyens et les
compétences pour le mettre en oeuvre
j'ai parlé de l'emploi tout à l'heure et
je chante comme socio éducatif
je suis constant sur le rythme scolaire
à quatre jours je n'ai pas changé d'avis
je leur d'études a été supprimée par
monsieur rabelais par monsieur malandain
kim et 1500 en forme deux offres dans
leurs 30 tous les jours
alors moi je veux bien qu'on règle les
problèmes et être cohérent et constant
vidalies les trappistes et c'est un
projet de changement qui va falloir
choisir
dimanche le seul changement réel
crédible et financé aujourd'hui c'est
celui que
mustapha leur ba oui parce que nous
cherchons pas à diviser les trappistes
où elle est coupée de leurs partenaires
mais bien à les rassembler et à voir
surtout des résultats concrets pour leur
quotidien leur cadre de vie et j'en vois
un internement à l'ensemble de notre
projet que nous avons été les pionniers
accueilli mme allende a fait intervenir
et vous avez réagi aussi pendant les
propos de mme anne massot et dali rabais
écoutez ça fait un certain nombre
d'années et que j'ai la responsabilité
de cette ville avec d'autres personnes
la première chose que je veux dire c'est
que ce que j'entends les gens
choisissent le produit qui colle c'est
que la ville de trappes aujourd'hui à
tous les niveaux c'est pas celle que
j'ai hérité par le suffrage universel
il est né il ya maintenant plusieurs
plusieurs années rien n'empêche il reste
du travail à faire et que quand on aime
une ville quand on a le souci quotidien
des habitants quand on a une philosophie
qui est d'abord le social l'humain le
partage l'égalité au maximum il reste
toujours quelque chose à faire
électrifier le critiquer ce qu'on a
envie repartir on s'est trompé on ne
peut changer et en tout cas
personnellement et avec eux ceux qui
sont restés fidèles qui n'ont pas trahi
et ceux qui viennent dans l'équipe on
est tout à fait disposé tout à fait
prêts à continuer à faire de trappes il
une ville dans laquelle les habitants
sont heureux d'habiter
or on est partagé et où tout le monde
est respecté dans sa diversité
car c'est une des caractéristiques
importantes de tra connais pas on n'est
pas dans des politiques politiciennes de
bahia où on et comment on est au service
des habitants dans leur diversité dans
leurs besoins elle est avec le souci de
d'humanité et de fraternité qui est la
marque de la gauche la vraie celle qui
pense d'abord aux gens sa carrière du
logement du logement social notamment
nombreux locataires se sont plaint aussi
de problèmes avec leur bail est
d'ailleurs on l'a entendu ces dernières
années on entendu pendant la campagne
également autre magnat through c'est
vous qui avaient le plus de retard vous
êtes avis minutes 12 ali rabo une minute
58 et guy malandain en 9 minutes 47
je vous demander vos propositions pour
agir en ce sens vous êtes intervenu
notamment auprès de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines cela va servir
à quoi ça va servir simplement à
inverser le rapport de force qui existe
aujourd'hui entre les locataires et les
bailleurs sociaux qui parfois ne
respectent pas leurs obligations légales
j'ai été le seul six années à alerter
avec une grande surdité de l'équipe
municipale en place faut se dire ou de
l'adjoint en charge de la célébrité je
suis désolé de le dire encore une fois
au promettre tout ce qu'on veut quand
pendant six années on n'a pas fait le
nécessaire
là nous avons un vrai sujet de désaccord
d'autres choses encore une fois le
client qui ceux qui pensent qu'ils vont
dans le bon sens dans la politique
municipale qui a été menée par national
romain j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire mais sur ce sujet de la qualité du
logement
on a laissé des bailleurs sociaux ne pas
respecter leur obligation d'entretien
leurs obligations de réparation
le niveau des charges qui parfois est
abusif parce qu'il n'y a pas de contrôle
demain la municipalité jouera pleinement
son rôle est tout simplement fera
appliquer la loi parce que c'est ça dont
on a besoin
mettre en demeure les barrières quand
ils ne font pas le nécessaire est il
normal que des familles attendu des
radiateurs pendant des mois et des mois
qu'il y aura les visites in quatre mois
sans chauffage ka paul langevin nous
ayons une dame une famille affectée
d'une mise lille etc etc
c'était pas moi qui ai inventé cette
réalité simplement il faut un vrai
changement et pendant six années les
élus n'ont pas été au rendez vous et
donc je suis allé chercher les
partenaires j'ai essayé de faire
pression avec les moyens qui sont les
miens parce que je voulais dire que le
rôle de la municipalité
ce serait celui-là donc l'agglomération
a fait un acte fort en arrêtant de
travailler avec le principal bailleur de
la ville
d'ailleurs valophis qui d'ailleurs est
ce en anglais avec les élus que j'ai en
face de moi et c'est leur droit le plus
légitime
encore une fois chacun a sa sensibilité
politique moi en ce qui me concerne je
ferai à toute la loi c'est vrai que les
bailleurs
c'est vrai les locataires qui ne
respectent pas les règles et c'est vrai
aussi au quotidien dans notre ville
puisque le sujet du logement est aussi
celui là nous avons besoin d'une police
municipale 24 h sur 24 7 jours sur 7
nous avons quatre fois moins de
policiers municipaux que les villes
voisines six amis que je le répète nous
avons besoin d'assurer la sécurité la
tranquillité
l'entretien
propreté pour les trappistes c'est la
moindre des choses c'est un droit
fondamental les autres villes y arrive
nous aurons cette exigence là demain si
les trappistes nous accordent leur
confiance ce que j'espère aller rabais
vous avez une minute trente à peu près
pour aborder ce sujet c'est très peu ce
sera pareil pour dim a longtemps mais
que vous ayez le temps ensuite de
conclure cette émission chacun sur la
thématique de votre choix ali rabais
parmi vos propositions on peut lire
aussi la création d'un service municipal
contre l'insalubrité ça servirait à quoi
ça fonctionnerait comment je vais
profiter de ce débat pour faire passer
un message aux bailleurs de trappes en
particulier aux deux plus gros valophis
et effi disque est devenu cdc habitat la
ville de trappes a changé de ton
vis-à-vis des bailleurs pour défendre
les droits des locataires de la ville de
trappes
vous le savez peut-être ou peut-être pas
mais la ville de trappes accepte
d'exonérer les bailleurs sociaux de la
taxe foncière sur les propriétés bâties
l'impôt foncier comme tous les
propriétaires de trappes le paye à
hauteur de 1 million 200 mille euros
chaque année
c'est un million deux cent mille euros
sont censés être versée par le
contribuable de fait aux bailleurs pour
qu'il puisse apporter un certain nombre
d'améliorations à l'habitat des
trappistes clairement aujourd'hui le
compte n'y est pas comme d'autres maires
de villes de gauche notamment je vais en
convoquer les bailleurs dans mon bureau
et nous allons négocier cette
exonération thèse pp et je dis
clairement aujourd'hui que je
n'hésiterai pas à supprimer
l'exonération de taxe foncière sur les
propriétés bâties
si les bailleurs ne change pas
radicalement d'attitude vis-à-vis des
bailleurs des locataires
la seconde mesure que nous prendrons
c'est que la mairie s'associera aux
amicales de locataires pour réaliser un
contrôle des charges systématique tous
les jours je suis interpellé par des
trappistes parce que je les croise
divine je vis au milieu d'eux qu'ils
payent parfois 250 300 euros quasiment
de charge
c'est à dire parfois l'équivalent du
loyer payé par les trappistes pour
habiter dans un f3 nous allons appliquer
le contrôle systématique des charges
pour pouvoir rattraper les bailleurs
quand il sur facture c'est
malheureusement trop fréquemment cas les
locataires la troisième proposition sur
le thème j'avancerai c'est la création
d'une bourse des changes de logements y
compris en interne ailleurs beaucoup de
foyers
beaucoup de familles qui vivent à deux
notamment les retraités dans un f5 parce
qu'ils ont eu des familles nombreuses et
des enfants qui ont quitté le foyer
ne veulent plus vivre dans ces extraits
mais continue de les occuper
privant ainsi des personnes qui vivent
sous occupation dans des les deux dans
des f3 la possibilité d'accès bien à 25
nous allons constituer un accord avec
les bailleurs comme le fait la ville de
paris pour avoir une bourse d'échangé de
logements et permettre à des familles
nombreuses et ville en lf2 de basculer
sur des f 5 et aux personnes qui vivent
dans des f-5 de d'accéder à des
logements plus petits à tarifs fixés et
enfin je souhaite donner le même fois en
10 secondes au look à palerme concours
ayant des régies de quartier je conclu
sur ce point
les trappistes peuvent eux-mêmes eux
mêmes constitués des associations que
nous appelons appelle des régies de
quartier dont l'objectif est
d'entretenir leurs bâtiments de faire le
ménage d'entretenir les espaces verts
c'est une façon de se rendre indépendant
des bailleurs guy malandain concernant
le logement logement social notamment à
l'intervention possible de la mairie
auprès des bailleurs
c'est une question de fond très
importante au niveau de la région
d'abord savoir
je vais parler tout à l'heure des les
bailleurs et des relation qu'on a avec
eux aux savoirs qui ici à trappes
il ya 4000 demandes de logements sociaux
qui sont en permanence déposés dont qui
viennent d'ailleurs de partout parce
qu'on leur dit et logements sociaux la
trappe donc d'aller vous inscrire allez
vous inscrire à ça et donc là je ne
saurai tout à fait mal aimable nous
avons dans l'agglomération mais pas
seulement un instrument
une série de communes qui préfèrent
payer payer payer plutôt que
d'accueillir une diversité volts au
logement je me suis occupé du programme
local de l'habitat que j'avais vie dans
une loi quand j'étais député pour pour
l'agglomération de saint quentin
je sais les difficultés que j'ai
rencontrées est ce que j'ai dû organiser
comme ça pour qu'elles se soient
acceptés au niveau haut niveau de l'état
la relation avec les bailleurs il ya 13
bayard 7800 logements sociaux c'est
quelque chose de compliqué mais deux
permanents
si l'on va pas organiser la relation que
les bailleurs je sais la semaine chaque
semaine j'ai un coup de téléphone et je
tiens à ce que mon travail simplement
avec l'ensemble des d'ailleurs ça pousse
ça pose des questions très très forte je
fais une centaine soit d'abord parce que
les élèves et on a affaire à des
institutions qui sont devenus très vaste
et donc la difficulté de la relation
pour dire oui lui fait de sable blanc et
est devenu est devenu très très
compliqué en revanche je ne crois pas du
tout que le coude semences excusez moi
monsieur dassault mais des émotions etc
soit une méthode l'exigence la sévérité
le travail avec les associations de
locataires
oui c'est heavy rain c'est une exigence
que sur mac a vu le jour à chauray
landes
je me dis je peux je peux le couvert
d'un événement d interrompre fumée jouer
sur la com ça sur des affaires financier
d'autant qu' il faut se rappeler une
chose c'est que quand on garantit les
emprunts dabaya on a la possibilité
d'attribuer des logements d'un
contingent de réserve quand on garantit
par nos pairs ce contingent de réserves
ça veut dire s'il tombe malade
je vous arrête là parce que vous avez
pris beaucoup d'avancé et à 12 12
minutes 12 minutes 30 de temps de parole
vous n'aurez pas du tout le temps de
deux coiffeurs suis navré on sauvera la
problématique du logement social qui tu
devrais pellematic particulièrement en
ile de france et auxquels il faut penser
au niveau du chemin du ballon d'un jeu
merci othman nasri ou si vous souhaitez
prendre une minute pour réagir encore
sur ce sujet là et ensuite nous passons
à vos conclusions et vous aurez plus ou
moins de temps les uns les autres en
fonction de vos attentes par l'autre
magna seront vous pouvez réagir encore
sur ce sujet vous avez plus d'une minute
de retard
bien sûr je constate qu'on me critique
sur le moyen que j'ai employé pour faire
bouger les lignes sur ce sujet là
simplement c'est le seul moyen de moins
je dispose et puisque je n'ai su par
responsabilité contrairement main sur
abbey national en a quand j'entends les
propositions qui sont faites aujourd'hui
si on va durcir le ton avec les
bailleurs que le la de vous créer ne
surent abékan c'était votre délégation à
la municipalité
c
dentellerie je me suis vraiment la
jeunesse passe or les trappes et que ça
tout va bien se passer vous est demandé
de réserver on va de l'avant jusqu'au
bout et ils préfèrent respect qui est dû
aux électeurs puisque on ne peut pas
leur dire qu'on fera demain linverse de
ce qu'on a fait pendant six années
oui il faut rééquilibrer la relation et
faire appliquer la loi et moi je n'ai
pas peur de le dire je suis attaché au
respect de la loi et donc naturellement
à s'applique aussi aux bailleurs c'est
ce que j'ai essayé de faire parce que je
suis élu d'opposition je lui parlais
neuvier la municipalité n'est pas le
dialogue avec les bailleurs et donc j'ai
demandé aux partenaires qui ne comprend
pas d'ailleurs le sujet accra parce que
c'est un sujet propre train parce que il
n'ya 4 a malheureusement que la
municipalité ne va pas au bout de sa
responsabilité sur ce sujet là je suis
heureux d'abord avec des suivis par les
parieurs
c'est une réalité que vivent beaucoup de
locataires et quand j'entends maintenant
les propositions de mes adversaires je
constate que ce que j'avais prêté
pendant six ans j'ai démissionné du
conseil de surveillance il passe pas
d'ailleurs de la ville j'ai dit il y
avait des dysfonctionnements et des
adultes s'étaient pas aujourd'hui dans
2017 ou et des deux concurrents que j'ai
en face de moi sur ce sujet avec tout le
respect que j'ai pour nationale on a
d'autres sujets général à lui reprocher
sur ce sujet là la municipalité a été
défaillante et il va falloir un vrai
changement pour ramener ce changement de
ton dont monsieur rap et nous parlait à
l'instant mais qui n'a jamais été en
capacité de mettre en oeuvre quand ils
en avaient la possibilité aux temps de
parole respectifs ali rabat 11 minutes
24 ottomane nassour 11 minutes 39 et 10
malandain 12 minutes 35 nous allons
passer aux conclusions de ce débat et
nous allons bien servait à dire à mettre
à lire à ben ali
oui bien sûr on entend des abeilles
franchement je suis désolé non à l'irb
et vous m'excuserez le laissez moi
terminer l'émission je le disais donc
nous passons conclusions de ce débat
nous conservons l'ordre d'enregistrement
préfecture je rappelle que vous êtes
libre du choix du sujet que vous voulez
aborder il ya deux consignes que je vous
demande de respecter de ne pas
interrompre le un autre candidat et de
respecter ce temps de parole nous
débutons avec othman nation pour
engagement trappe citoyens vous avez une
minute trente pour conclure on voit que
dans une élection on peut toujours tout
dire qu'elle mange invite les électeurs
à regarder les actes les compétences les
moyens les parcours des uns et des
autres en détail
en ce qui me concerne j'ai eu un souci
tout au long de cette élection de
rassembler je ne crois pas que un mandat
municipal soit un mandat artiste et je
pense ont alors fait la démonstration
avec des élus qui sont pas de ma
sensibilité qui sont venus au sein du
conseil municipal d'abord
à quatre élus de la gauche chrono
national en deuil ont considéré qu'il
fallait qu'on écrit ensemble l'avenir de
la ville et puis avec mon staff alors
oui cette liste d'union locale qui est
représentative des trappistes est bon
que moi je ne demande pas aux gens ce
qu'ils votent aux élections nationales
par contre je leur demande d'être
cohérent sur le projet qu'on vous ne
voulons mettre en oeuvre sur la réussite
scolaire sur la sécurité qui n'est pas
un tabou sur les questions d'emploi sur
laquelle nous avons un vrai constat
d'échec attrape sur le fait que l'équipe
municipale qui est aujourd'hui
profondément déchiré profondément divisé
et qui promet pour demain à linverse de
ce qu'elle a fait pendant six années
n'est plus en capacité de prob améliorer
le cadre de vie des trappistes les
trappistes mérite mieux que la gestion
qu'ils ont aujourd'hui je considère un
travail important a été fait durant
vingt années nos fronts demain ce qu'il
faut pour que les trappistes encore une
ford puisse se rassembler être dans un
climat d'apaisement et de sérénité et
avoir plus d'efficacité dans le service
public qui leur est rendue et je les
invite à ne pas croire la démagogie la
communication des attaques personnelles
sur les lieux de résidence des heures d
autres qui sont bien sûr des
informations toujours erronée nous
sommes sur une élection sur le fond
c'est sur le fond gouvenement d'autres
rapide de nous faire confiance dit
malandain c'est à vous vous avez trente
secondes pour conclure pour trappe la
gauche qui agit et bien c'est assez
simple 30 secondes pour dire à mes
concitoyens que je suis toujours à leur
disposition pour que la ville qui a
évolué je le disais tout à l'heure
pendant les 20 dernières années continue
à évoluer sur les mêmes principes qui
sont des principes de respect des
personnes de solidarité de laïcité enfin
bref les principes de la gauche
républicaine et ce qui m'étonne toujours
dans ces débats c'est tout ce que vont
faire ceux qui n'ont jamais rien fait et
donc ça doit être sans doute le miracle
des campagnes électorales
c'est que c'est la fête puisque ce
qu'ils ont fait précédemment
c'est à vous allez c'est à vous pour la
conclusion
guy malandain vous m'excuserez voilà je
disais c'est à vous vous avez une minute
40 pour conclure un premier mot rapide
pour revenir sur le logement et dure une
chose à monsieur nasro
il faut si vous êtes attachés au respect
de la loi comme vous venez de m'indiquer
convaincre vos amis maires des villes de
droite de 50 en yvelines le respecter le
quota de 25 % de logements sociaux fixé
par la loi depuis des années maintenant
si à voisins le bretonneux obstruent les
logements sociaux qu'il manque la
l'agglomération les trappistes peut-être
pourrait demain s'il le souhaite
demander à déménager dans un logement
social à voisins le bretonneux
c'est une possibilité qu'il faut leur
offrir et pour cela il faut que chaque
ville prenne ses responsabilités c'est
aussi ça le respect de la loi à vous
convaincre vos collègues maires de
droite pour revenir sur ma conclusion
moi j'ai fait une campagne uniquement
axée sur les propositions
je ne suis pas dans le dénigrement la
critique de mes adversaires j'ai du
respect pour guy malandain aux côtés de
duquel j'ai travaillé pendant six ans je
suis j'ai été adjoint au maire à la
jeunesse et aux sports pendant six ans
c'est pour cela que les trappistes me
connaissent ils connaissent mon bilan
est bon travail et je me propose
d'utiliser la même et la même énergie le
même dynamisme
accompagné d'une équipe est réouvert
renouvelée rajeunie pour mettre en
oeuvre nos preuves alors ma priorité ce
sera vraiment nos enfants l'éducation la
préparation du basculement de la ville
de trappes à la semaine de quatre jours
à la prochaine rentrée scolaire
le rétablissement du soutien scolaire
effectivement manque à nos enfants
attrapent et je mettrai le paquet sur
ces éléments dès la prochaine rentrée la
création d'activités périscolaires de
qualité et d'excellence
le mercredi matin qui seront offerts
qu'aux trappistes trois heures
d'activités périscolaires de qualité le
respect de la relation également
partenariat entre la municipalité les
élus les services municipaux et les
directeurs d'école les enseignants et
les parents d'élèves
cette relation est cassé aujourd'hui il
faudra la rétablir et je proposerai un
pacte de confiance aux instituteurs de
notre ville et pour conclure je suis le
seul quand date rapide
il se propose à vos suffrages je suis
celui qui vit à habitat trappe qui fait
ses courses à tra qui s'épanouit apte à
lui qui propose une liste 100% crappy
pour les temps de parole des uns et des
autres vous êtes tous quasiment à
égalité une dizaine de secondes qui va
vous séparer sur la fin de ce débat
merci à vous trois d'avoir participé
concernant cette commune de trappes
débat à revoir sur tv 78 points comme
dans tous les autres débats que nous
vous avons proposé rendez vous
le dimanche 28 juin et dès 19h45 sur
notre antenne et sur radio sensations
pour la soirée du second tour pour
suivre l annonce des résultats dans les
yvelines et entendre les principales
réactions merci aussi aux auditeurs de
radio marmite qui émet depuis trappe de
nous avoir suivi et à très bientôt merci
encore à vous trois remercier vous va
[Musique]